a long long time ago in a galaxy
far away naboo was under an attack
you guys know that song
american pie yeah it's a classic
[Laughter]
it's a great song for you youngins out
there who missed that parody guys we're
gonna watch
star wars the bad batch today
episode 9. and guys if you end up
enjoying this video please do make sure
to subscribe and click that bell and
also hit that like button
full length watch along is where you
sync up with the time code for this over
patreon got a bunch of shows over there
where there's also reaction highlights
included for many of them at the same
tier
thank you guys for being here you know
like
star wars is star wars is so cool
that is the quote of the day that is it
yeah star wars
so cool so where's the bomb also big
thanks to pratham jindal for editing
these highlights together for us let's
get down to business
[Music]
he invented star wars what
everybody hates that guy
when he started that bounty hunter the
only vessel in our scanners is
crosshairs
and he's right on top of us no way
don't let them get away crosstalk just
immediately got right back to business
prepping to jump not without omega the
bounty hunter who took her is long gone
will have no chance of finding them if
crosshair shoots us down
oh the shields are failing
make the jump
yeah this is already like a really cool
first 30 seconds
ah it's like uh the phantom menace
looking for your communication device it
has been confiscated and placed in a
secure compartment
i see it lit me out of here
mr bane does not respond well to
prisoners who are
difficult but he does bring his own
music cue
how's my asset doing my name
is omega where are you taking me
but when will you have time to fix my
leg it is quite inconvenient
my leg remind me about this when we're
doing this review
all right what is her condition
alive so i expect a premium
i'll be at the rendezvous bring my
unlocked credits
i will deliver the payment and retrieve
omega
done away you will go to our abandoned
facility on boardville
once you have retrieved the genetic
material needed
terminate her terminate her
no no she cares yeah she cares
that kevin owens got a conscience
i could fix your leg i am a techno
service droid i am
quite capable of completing my own
repairs
you are a prisoner and are not to be
trusted
have it your way burger king your
description of the bounty hunter is a
match to one from the republic's files
[Music]
cad bane he had multiple run-ins with
the jedi and was responsible for
attempting to abduct chancellor
palpatine i further analyzed omega's
genetic profile and discovered she has
pure
first generation dna
all clones were created from a host
named django yes
while our genetic structure was modified
for growth acceleration and obedience
omega is a pure genetic replication how
many clones like that exist
there's only one other a male clone
alpha
later referred to as boba boba yes yes
boba
yes
see if it contacts know anything we'll
keep monitoring comes
[Applause]
yeah oh man that's why she's so okay
will you just let me help you you are a
prisoner
exactly not like i can escape off this
ship
that is a valid point i'm only a kid
oh all right but make it quick and not a
word of this to anyone
boba is called alpha she's omega
[Laughter]
how long have you been working for him
many years i am his trusted confidant
we are a team we are lovers it's not
very nice to you
on the contrary my treatment is
perfectly adequate
it is misaligned you will need to adjust
the calibration
oh my yes that's working it feels spring
oh it's only temporary
good where did you hide my comm device
albane's gonna catch on to you
absolutely
toto get your chassis up here i can't
see anything in this job
get up here
[Laughter]
more sensitive in the bad patch just
leave us
i don't even care about the body
what's taking so long
what up where's the kid mr bane she's
quite obviously right
there
hello is anyone there can you hear me
omega
[Music]
forward
i don't know where i am we're covered
for you
the signal's too weak to establish a
direct connection trace
i'm trying to can you create
a paddle nearby there's one by a door
first see if you can activate it
it worked now what should i do
i still can't get a good
it really does feel brand new
oh she also fixed it yeah yeah she
really did fix it
because she's just that good of a guy i
am not going with you
you're lucky they want you alive who
wants me
you'll soon find out
i told you you'd be sorry when my
friends showed up
oh no torn way
she needs help none you can give
he's right oh
they know each other that's my case
you're holding
hand it over and i'll let you walk god
these shots and this fog
the case for the girl sounds fair
you first
i have the case
give me the whip i'll throw you the idol
i have the case
[Music]
no he's so sweet y'all are the credits
the credits
find a kid i am on it
come on make that power surge you should
know when to quit fans
you gotta know when to hold them chand
one looks so gorgeous yeah very moody
time stones
snokes wait
those are clones that's my guess
what else would they be what
huh
she's in the leader system i'm
pinpointing the exact coordinates hang
on were those kevin knowing clubs
i couldn't tell what their dimensions
were i mean they didn't look like
they had those crazy long necks but do
not worry i will recover the target
i will not fail you they won't get here
in time
no the only person you can rely on is
yourself
why did you kill torn way part of the
job you should thank me
what the prime minister has planned for
you is far worse than why i'm here
what does he want me for you already
know the answer oh they are
yeah i think those are i'm trying to
help you you said the same thing on
pantora
there you are you are coming with me
it's too late for that it's time to go
oh grudge oh
gross oh no
they look like the signs aliens when
they come out of there
that's a great girl
[Music]
playtime's over little
[Music]
ouchy
[Music]
there's something so excited about
watching the fight
betting versus cat paid hell yes
the aesthetic of this really looks like
the cloud city and um
empire strikes back going for the flight
pod
that will not get you very far
you are coming with me
i don't know that one
the mandalorian they show that she's
like a really good martial artist too
i don't remember seeing as much of her
like fist fighting abilities but
but i feel like she did some
hand-to-hand stuff
where do you think you are going
you'll be sorry
nice shot
[Laughter]
the best droid delivery
[Music]
oh
it's harder than it looks
[Music]
great attention to detail on that
oh boy
you got this hunter's gonna be flying in
the sky to catch you
[Music]
wreckers is gonna catch you with his
bare hands
good to have you back kid
now also show your force sensitive and
that you're a palpatine club
throw it all in are you okay omega are
you hurt
just emotionally happening why are the
kevin nolans after me
you're valuable to them
you're different different a freak
get us in the air i am trying but our
systems are not responding
they appear to have been sabotaged
but that means cad bane will be back oh
yeah
everyone will be back omega was rescued
by the same clones i encountered on
pantora i can track
but that will cost extra no
as long as she is not in the hands of
llamas she is safe
i will transfer your payment if you
change your mind you know how to reach
me
it's just so many different for
different purposes
all internal network marketing of bounty
hunters
bounty hiring you take on five bounties
and then get five friends to help you
with their own five bounties
i don't want to end up an experiment in
a tube
that's not gonna happen if i'm as
valuable as you say
lama sue will keep sending bounty
hunters after me
he can send everyone in the galaxy you
have us
you can't fight them all omega you don't
have to worry
you are never going back to camino
promise i promise oh yay what a nice
episode
another cool episode yeah i quite
enjoyed that one
it's a lot of fun it's very it was
thrilling it was different it was
refreshing
yeah yeah swashbuckling but also a good
amount of peril
batch is barely in it i know they really
are just on the periphery they're on the
margins just trying to get to
the main action how do you go look at
this shot of uh
of uh cat bane's um his noggin
plate it looked like he had a plate
there yeah then i got to compare to an
older photo
to be sure that i see what i think i'm
seeing i think you're on track
all right so going back and then
honestly doing a google search on my
phone some people already
pointed it out apparently that the plate
he uh it looked like he had a plate on
his head
and that is most likely in reference to
the episode that never
got to see the light of day of that we
talked about in the last episode
of boba versing um cad bane
so i i would take i would assume that
that event already happened then that
we're not going to see it happen in this
show
that probably maybe we'll see a
flashback to it which would be pretty
cool
to get there um but yeah i was like wait
a minute something's off but i couldn't
quite tell
so i had to i had to look it up and yeah
stan i thought i could have pointed
something out and maybe other people
didn't point out but i'm late late
to the party watch look at the party's
reactions to you by the way hi guys
uh but i i really enjoyed this one it
was refreshing in the sense that
you you don't really spend much time
with the bad bachelor group
themselves and i love the like intense
immediacy
of it and they they kept it very
intriguing
and it was uh gripping intense
and there's like like hunting
western mood that they had all on this
planet
which i'm not remembering the name of
but i think this is where the cam
is that where the kaminoans are from
there's so much to unpack here
all right so really quick the camera
notes
that they clone themselves too are are
they like a species
that exists not through natural breeding
but through cloning
because that's the vibe that i was
getting from that review i don't know
much about the kaminoans but yeah
that moment had me questioning uh their
whole race in that particular moment
yeah and i mean are they the ones doing
it to perpetuate their own
uh resiliency or is somebody else just
creating kaminoans for their own
ends you know but that's their base that
like that is their
facility i'm just trying to make sure
i'm getting my my facts right
star wars star wars more than any other
world of
fantasy fiction out there the easiest
thing for me to get
things mixed up is star wars undoubtedly
all right so anything i get wrong just
or anything i'm not recalling properly
either
by uh position or title or label
whatever
just tell me all right just tell me uh
bottom line you still keep up with the
immediacy of what's happening in the
show
so yeah that matt had my mind going and
then
of course with omega that's like the
biggest reveal that they got here i mean
there's been all these theories going
around like she force sensitive is she
the start of the palpatine clones
is she a palpatine clone what is she
exactly
but if i'm remembering correctly the
clones they need to shift away from them
because that dna strand is weakening so
of jango fett the thing that at first
created all the clones
and the the only pure the pure
clone the one who's an exact replica of
django um
would be boba fett so then call him
alpha she's omega she's just a female
version of it
in order to keep their the cloning
process going and to enhance them and
make them
you know the best they can be they would
need her dna
which maybe isn't as exciting as you
know like force sensitive and
and palpatine theories and such but i
love the
the connection and tie-in that they did
with her because that is a very
very that does still make her very
important and you get why she's so
important because her dna is so
necessary for the kaminoans to continue
on because it seems like they never
thought the war would ever
end and they never thought that the
empire would be like you know we don't
want your clones anymore we're just
gonna
do conscriptions so in order to
re-increase the value of the clones
yeah they need her yeah we got to get
pure
clones now but i'm surprised they
weren't already working on that
beforehand
at the start of the offset of this show
they it was they were already
kind of in this position where they were
having cloning issues
um not that they couldn't do it it's
just the strand wasn't as strong
so yeah i don't know why they weren't
already attempting we're already just
harvesting omega's sweet sweet genetics
well it's because of the kaminoan lady
whose name i've been protecting her yeah
yeah i think it's so funny because you
got the prime minister who's like
okay you got the empire's like i don't
really need her just wipe out the bad
batch then i'm like okay then the
kaminoans are crap we're so under the
thumb
of the empire but we need her we're
gonna lose our contract man we gotta get
her back let's get her let's hire a
bounty to get her back and then she's
like all right i'm gonna hire a
different bounty
to protect her it's just like so
jumbled up what's going on here
everybody's gotta bounty out on omega
for something
yeah yeah this the story of the bad
batch seems to be
so much about like what it means to be
human
and survival so much of the tones and
themes that are explored here which i
i really do appreciate and it's usually
wrapped up in a just a visually
beautiful show yeah yeah one also these
these ideas of having to kind of grapple
with
the circumstances you were born into
and in this case that were like
engineered upon you so like that's
an added layer of like not
body horror necessarily but it's like
something very dramatically jarring to
be like man i was engineered and like
you know to go from the bad batch stuff
in the previous episodes especially with
wrecker dealing with the chip and
everything and then to come over here
and to have omega commodified so much as
just you know like a pile of ripe
genetics like it is
it takes on this much bigger sinister
tone partly to that at least for me yeah
um and then also to have so much of this
episode taking place
in an abari in an area that feels
abandoned and it feels like ravaged by
something
that's the main thing that threw me
about where exactly we were just because
whenever we cut to the camanos the main
camerons you know they're in a place
that
does not look desolate and you know
rendered
by something or abandoned by something
yeah but i think they have like
they must have like several facilities
yeah yeah yeah
maybe or or you know a couple different
planets
they operate on me all right just tell
me these
these very specific details are the
things that sometimes my memory does not
harvest as well all right uh at this
but bottom line like what this episode
gave us was some really cool information
while still giving us um an action-based
episode but the kind of action i love
where it's rooted in an intention
like i i thought it was neat of watching
just you know fenix chan who's
fairly new to star wars uh considering
you know how long star wars has been
like cad bane is more of a character
brought back a nostalgic piece for fans
of clone wars to finally come into the
fray
and then uh for a bad batch and then you
got fenix shan
who is beginning more and more popular
as of late and then to watch these
bounty hunters come together to have to
fight each other for different purposes
and also
you know like fennec it's such a
confusing
character in the sense of what is the
real intent is she
only only going for omega
because she's hired right or she
actually
cares is there a part of her that does
care about her because she is indeed a
little girl
yeah yeah yeah and you you can't quite
tell because i was watching it
i was thinking oh i feel like you
actually are protecting her and looking
out for her then
she was hired to do it yeah yeah yeah
but you know yeah it's
it's that question of what is your
actual
investment because also we've seen her
do some
type of selfless things for other small
special children in the star wars yeah
but this is much earlier than that so
well you know what this really provided
it provided the bounty hunter tone yeah
yeah yeah like you're really just in the
world of bounty hunters
yeah that's what it mainly lean in on
because the other episodes
the bad batches or one of the characters
at least whether it be wrecker hunter
are very prevalent in those episodes and
this is the first time you you
they're they're really supporting
characters yeah this one
really lets omega kind of take the lead
and then have cad bane to be like the
main
support you know yes and then fenic is
the sort of breath of surprise you know
and breath of relief and i thought that
was cool because almost in depriving you
of the bad batch
it helps to enhance the tension i think
because yeah it's like you know you know
that omega's got something special about
her and that she's probably capable
enough
because of all the trouble she's gotten
him before to handle herself on this but
also yeah she doesn't have that safety
net and even though you know they're
gonna get back together at some point i
thought it was pretty effective having
them
trying to communicate across uh you know
a long distance of space and them
trying to help her find a way to get a
beacon to them like
it had a lot of uh like parallel actions
running to really enhance the tension
while also then being able to take its
time with those really cool standoffs
and stuff
between uh shand and uh cad bane well it
there was a suspenseful quality and
due to the immediacy of the chase and
the urgency of the situation and i
really like seeing that uh
complex care come through hunter
like this was the of losing her you
really see hunter
like that that
that association as audiences sorry i'm
not speaking clearly at all during this
guys
but that association of
how we're like oh yeah hunter's kind of
like the new dad to omega
that really shined through in his little
bit of performance in this particular
episode
because he was so determined yeah
we're not doing anything but saving her
yeah the only thing
that matters right now is rescuing her
absolutely and then that little
bit at the end that little moment at the
end when they're finally reunited and
he's like
no one's ever gonna like you're never
going back to the camera owens we are
gonna be
we're gonna protect you like no matter
what and i like this structural approach
because
clone wars and we've touched on this
before of how that show
will spend there'll be sever many
episodes where you don't see certain
characters
because there's so many different
characters to focus on and while it all
does come together
it's like even with season seven there's
not much anakin skywalker
in in in the final season of clone wars
which makes sense for what they did
uh but that's just one example right and
then here i
i like that they still keep the bad
batch in it
but this is a great way to put your
focus elsewhere
yeah and to show that it's not basically
dependent on
their presence to work this the urgency
of this episode gave a good
like kind of like a video game vibe yeah
yeah i'm going to work through calms and
then
sneaking around and getting into your
fight scenes there was a cool video game
layer to it this is like six levels in
when it's like okay now you're gonna
play as the character you don't normally
play as
yeah yeah now you're gonna have to
communicate with the players you
normally play
yeah yeah it was awesome yeah it was
really awesome stuff yeah
just like cad bane just brings such a
great presence about him
uh and every time like even just his
return in the last couple minutes of the
previous episode bring such a presence
and not just because it's like oh cad
bane's back
uh but just seeing him here again you
know you're like i don't even need
scenes where
there's other people on screen with him
yeah it's just that captivating
absolutely and that voice yeah that like
deep
uh silky voice yeah man it's hard not to
want to just listen to her
he's a really great character but yeah
guys uh the bad batch episode 11 what
did you guys think about this
episode leave your thoughts down below
how do you feel about the reveal
of who omega really is her significance
here
where do you think the show's going uh i
i particularly enjoyed this one
it felt it was nice to get like a a
moody tense episode and just a
completely different atmosphere
you know because the other ones that one
that i'm like oh it's so cinematic and
dark
so it's literally that it's like super
dark like lighting it's incredibly
like oh [ __ ] everything's so shadowed
and you can't really quite make out what
it is you gotta make a thumbnail really
punch that thing
you know kill it with brightness and
contrast
yeah and that this was it was a
different kind
like darkness was in the mood of being
in the fog and while you're in this like
i like kind of that ironic juxtaposition
of you're in the clouds it's foggy it's
bright it's sunshine yeah
yet uh it's a desolate like you said
abandoned
atmosphere yeah and i think that's what
made it such like a western vibe to it
as well
yeah well like like cowboys fighting in
the in a ghost town or something
yeah yeah yeah and a ghost town and a
dust storm or something because you get
all that visual obstruction to add
tension but also with this beautiful
golden cloudy quality yes yeah this is a
clever
clever way to give you the visual
tension
in a way that you're not used to seeing
it
what you think about this episode leave
your thoughts down below subscribe hit
that bell click that like button yadda
yadda yadda
correct me on anything because i need it
i do
i do see you guys
you